[Musique]
je pourrais vous demander cette danse et
vous pourriez répondre que vous n'en
avez pas envie alors je vous dis
réellement une autre fois peut-être mais
je pourrais aussi ne pas vous le
demandez rien à ces de ton avis néant
dont il est question
tu le connais à peine c'est presque un
étranger le problème c'est que je sais
que c'est le bon
[Musique]
j'étais ma bulle je ne me sens pas très
bien
ça ne va pas je fais pas bougé mettez le
tout réduire à terre
les gens paralysé par la polio ne vivent
pas longtemps il ne peut plus bouger à
part la tête ni respirer sans aide
comment peux tu revenir à 6 c'est une
question d'habitude
je t'aime et je veux que je m'attende le
connaissent
tu ne peux pas ému ce que je suis oui je
ne peux je dois pouvoir faire quelque
chose faite moi sortir d'ici l'avait pas
quitté l'hôpital personne dans la
situation de votre mari ne plus vivre
hors de nos idoles qui est un at il déjà
tenté est-ce que ça ma chérie je me sens
mieux je peux aller 5 livres que vous
n'y arriverez pas pari tenu
cherry a pelleté dit j'ai eu une idée
une chaise roulante qui respire pour lui
vous sûr que c'est sans danger jusqu'ici
c'est fonctionne à ben tu me dois cinq
livres j'arrive pas à le croire
pourquoi garder vous handicapez en
prison personne ne croyait possible de
vivre comme vous nous devrions ouvrir
les barrières et les libérer ça c'est
merveilleux on fait le tour du monde
ce serait une belle à frontières 6
quand je suis devenu paralysé j'ai voulu
mourir
ma femme m'a dit que je devais bible
pour voir grandir notre fils
ta vie et ma vie
je ne veux pas me contenter de survivre
je veux vivre réellement
[Musique]
nomura
mach
il devrait être à l'hôpital non vous
avez raison non
[Musique]